[Music]
so Monday morning they come in is a
bunch of flies and for some reason
they're only by our desk see him baby
yeah we don't have fly swatters so this
is the like most agile thing we found I
think the best plan is for us to just
act like we're working
Wow oh my glasses
I'm sorry glasses No hey window gets
shifted so we're just gonna go back to
work like no flies are there and we'll
just wait
hopefully we'll kill some flies let's
try it so this guy tweeted us a photo of
this pretend game he was gonna make of
basically the stop-motion video that we
did well he made the game
Jake Jake eNOS must be embracing a great
disclaimer alexander moon where's my
mouse embrace it embrace the gene came
in friend bracelet okay you're not
embracing it so here's the game look at
that that's me relentless jump yep I
guess this is his like character
animation node graph for me so like
these are all like your events and
reactions that my character can have in
this video game he says he claims that
he just rushed all of this and just made
it super janky it is a little janky but
it's also super awesome alexander moon
he's on your coffee he's on the cupcakes
if there's no body
he's still going the stretching
technique and get some cakes he's gonna
go play pool he's gonna go for it
you see him you just went that way so
hit the fly from the side where the
light isn't shining which is kind of
hard in this room but you know how I can
always take out a lamp just increase the
lamp it's plugged there if you're headed
this way the lamp will be there stay up
there
I see three there are three do not spray
the light technique worked yes we hit
him from this side and there was no
shadow cast over the fly
I read when you drive that thing around
my toes you guys like Archer there's
Archer stuff there's a Hellboy fist you
need a fist for anything it's ceramic I
give my lootcrate to my wife who then
gives it to a kid that she nannies and
he loves them looks forward to it every
month I used to really like half a meal
says I've got some cousins down in
Orange County that really used some toys
just pretend I never opened this there
we go office gives us boxes warning not
to use maximum penalty three years in
prison
[Music]
let's go one more passive wobbly we
killed one fly who might have been the
ringleader of the fly gang they'll be
back just got to hold the line can I say
that he flies right past my
I hit him I hit him
[Music]
as you guys now we are almost done with
our big video game projects which we'll
be sharing more about soon but there's
almost another big project a little bit
of a secret but I can share one small
aspect with you we have a document here
that I must sign and once I sign it it
means we're committed to doing the
project to be really cool you know every
project has its own challenges
specifically to them and this one will
have them nonetheless and in the spirit
of just you know seeing what happens
when you commit multiple months to be
alive through projects here we go see
what happens
all right sign man this is like really
heavy stuff have you think this is gonna
turn out fine hope they like those
little mouse yeah the nice thing was
that the easy bread thing yeah it's
gonna be a series called lifeline sci-fi
time-travel piece right now there's some
pretty good scripts on it they need a
little bit of work but generally it's a
cool story good characters more than
anything else it's the biggest project
we've ever worked on they'll be cool hey
at least it's going on our channel
probably maybe announced here both of
them
we found the spawn point it's wrens
garbage which hasn't been taken out in
over a week
turn out in the spawn point right now
these are all the lies where